is our job this is it from Fox News
North Dakota man who killed an 18 year
old boy following political argument has
charges reduced oh so this story is
actually from a couple weeks ago yeah
but uh we overlooked it and a lot of
people are not picking the story up you
may remember the story it's this guy
Shannon Brandt he apparently called the
police called some kid he claimed this
this 18 year old kid was a republican
extremist and then ran him over
they charged him with murder recently
they dropped it down to manslaughter and
they're saying it wasn't part of a plea
agreement meaning the prosecutors just
quietly were like we're going to reduce
his charges on this one yo it feels more
and more like across the country if you
if you like Donald Trump if you are a
conservative if you're libertarian if
you oppose the establishment they will
throw not just the book but any book
they have at you
there is unquestionably political
motivation against conservatives and
Libertarians people that are that are
generally anti-establishment there is a
strong strong incentive uh to do
everything you can to punish those
people for their opinions I don't think
that there's a there's gonna be people
that are going to say no that's not true
and stuff I really find it difficult to
see anything else you got 20 the the
riots in 2020 people like this guy kill
a kid dude he hit somebody with his car
after a political argument yeah after a
political argument that's like that's an
extremely important part this is a
politically motivated murder there was
that kid in uh how could that here's the
thing like to drop it to manslaughter I
mean how could it be unintentional way
to hit somebody with a car and he ran
well yeah this guy manslaughter are you
out of your mind he got into an argument
with someone and ran it do it over with
his car I think the kids were like
dancing in the street or something and
he had known the kid and he called him a
republican extremist ends up running the
kid over uh they said he fled the scene
and they upgraded the charges to felony
murder probably because he fled yeah and
uh they said he has also been charged
with leaving the scene of a crash that
resulted in death and now not because of
plea agreement they just said
as we have points out at the beginning
there's no evidence to support the
misplaced allegation of intentional
homicide the state and defense forensic
experts have provided a comprehensive
reports confirming the tragedy was an
accident misplaced media hype and
Community conjecture is no substitute
for evidence Mr brand is anxious for the
truth to be told to a jury trial Fair
Point Fair Point let's see let's see a
jury trial I'll say this innocent until
proven guilty extends to even people
like this and uh maybe it is media hype
but like when you charge him with
fleeing a crime you have to understand
why we feel that way so don't don't say
it's misplaced media when y'all
literally charged a guy with leaving the
scene of a crime that resulted in death
so like he says it's a republican
extremist runs him over it leaves and
then you're like as an accident
wow yeah but I guess is going to argue
that he ran him over and thought it was
a rabbit well but that's the thing right
because there was a prior relationship
here they clearly didn't like each other
political argument there was no prior
relationship between Jordan Neely and
Daniel Penny he was threatening people
on the subway so he intervened right it
was just clearly situational this is a
little a little different take on it but
listen if you're a conservative or if
you're a Libertarian I know you got a
life and stuff but if you get put onto a
jury stay like get in there and get on
the jury and if it happens to be someone
that has political leanings that align
with you jury nullification is a great
tool look at this headline from the
original story man admits to running
over 18 year old after they had a
political argument
unbelievable
see he admitted he admitted to running
over the teenager
leaving the scene of a crime
after having a political argument and
they're like nice one
yo if you're a trump supporter and you
fart they're gonna lock you up yeah
they're gonna be like what was that I
smell something yeah well you smelt it
Delta Act of 1987. you know and this
isn't what this is in Montana was it or
Wyoming North Dakota North Dakota North
Dakota I mean it's it's not typically a
Bastion of progressive liberalism there
you know I mean there are definitely
Democrats I would imagine blue dog
Democrats like the kid called his mom
said it was being chased it's like this
is premeditated this is this is first
degree yeah it's amazing they called it
felony murder I'm like this is prima
he's chasing the kid the kid calls mom
saying he's being chased we don't have a
justice system in the gun this country
anymore you know we talked about it's
drunk too this guy oh my gosh
like if you're if you're driving drunk
and you hit somebody you get charged
with like vehicular homicide negligent
homicide this is crazy whether it be the
whether it be the the stuff with George
Floyd or with the on that Aubry case or
with this or it's like very frequently
there is significantly you know
significantly bad bad prosecutions and
stuff you know I mean the FBI going
after Trump with the the stuff that came
out with the Durham case all that I I
don't see how people can continue to
trust the justice system when there are
so many high profile abuses of the you
know of the justice system it's it's
it's detrimental to the the country they
want you to wear an antifa shirt
it's the only way you'll get you'll get
justice but then they want you promoting
those ideas it's it's it's I'm half
kidding but it's kind of like how
businesses put up antifa stuff in their
Windows yeah I was in uh we were we were
out in the West Virginia area uh we're
working on the cafe and I see some of
these businesses having lgbtq plus
flyers in their Windows oh yeah and I'm
like a lot of these businesses probably
don't care someone comes in says okay
put something in the window say fine but
some of them especially in West Virginia
are like please don't hurt me you can
put whatever you want in the window
please spare our store that was like the
line from the 2020 riots please spare
our store because he's far left us are
going around and destroying every like
dude if you're a small business you
can't afford to replace your front
windows I'm talking thousands of dollars
this makes me wonder if this is like
what the french Terror was like how
intense were the the the leftists in in
the French Revolution you know how
intense were they going after the
population to to terrorize them into
agreeing I can't imagine that it was you
know significantly more intense than
least 2020. well they were beheading
people
uh that's true yeah a lot of people's
pretty bad and let it turned on
themselves yeah yeah Rob spear was like
oh no they blew his job let that but let
that be a lesson to what's going to
happen to these people the revolution
eats its own children but Society was
Society was also significantly more
violent back then well look all I'm
saying is don't be surprised if they
start killing people we've already seen
Terror attacks from lefties On The Rise
I mean and they have literally said on
television we should kill them Jane
Fonda said murder is how we are going to
solve the problem yeah
well she didn't she she she's they asked
her what could we do and she says murder
and then they all immediately go no
she's joking she's joking and then she
rolls her eyes covering for her yeah
like she only joking man these people
are nuts Hanoi Jane yeah they're they're
they're getting crazy out there man so I
kind of feel like maybe this summer
we'll see some Shenanigans yeah but I
think 2024 summer is gonna get crazy I
am concerned about uh next year getting
into the uh the election
so I got to ask you
um during the covet riots in 2020 you
you've been covered I'm sorry not the
cover rights what's wrong with me covid
2020 rides a lot happened that year it
was a great time that's inflation right
yeah yeah it was a good time no I wanted
to ask uh as a a fighter when did you
start to get involved politically
yeah so I I started to get you know I've
always grew up conservative my whole
entire life but I really started to
really started to Branch out when I saw
that the media and all the athletes were
just shoving one way down your throat
the liberal way and I'm like why why is
no one else talking about conservative
beliefs and then I started to realize
like all these athletes like they don't
want to disrupt their gravy train
they're getting paid by these general
managers by these owners managers
whatever and if they say something
they're gonna be bagging you know
groceries at Walmart so I'm like you
know what I'm an independent contractor
for the UFC thank God for Dana White and
the UFC what they do letting us be uh
independent contractors we don't have to
get our voices muzzled we could say
whatever we want so you know my paycheck
is not affected by what I believe in and
what I stand for so you know that's when
I really started to come out I was just
sick of seeing the LeBron James way you
know it just you know defund the police
uh oh I care about equality and
Injustice and women's rights women's
rights bro LeBron you you abuse women
you got women in Chinese sweatshops
you're working for pennies on the dollar
you're making hundreds of Millions after
them how could you care about women's
rights when you're a woman abuser yeah
wow it's funny how you don't see these
people talk about creating real American
jobs no so that we can do away with
Sweatshop labor and help American
workers bring back Manufacturing
talking point the meet the Democratic
party or the media tells them to say
they just regurgitated it's just virtue
signal it's empty virtue signaling oh
it's nonsense so like what kind of
pressure has been put on I know you said
you're a private contractor but have
people sort of tried to step in the way
of that get clients in trouble get the
UFC in trouble absolutely so we had a we
had a Reebok was sponsor in the UFC and
they didn't sponsor me individually they
just sponsored the you know the company
they didn't sponsor me individually
after one of my fights they tried to
retract some of my statements saying oh
we don't stand for what Colby Covington
believes oh we're asking for him to get
fired from the UFC and Dana's just like
laughing like what can I independent
contractor can I ask what you said or is
this something you can say on air or no
I just you know I just you know after I
beat this guy that was all about uh
black lives matter I just you know I
crushed his dreams and I just you know
stood up for conservatism and I was
patriotic and they didn't like the way I
said it but it's crazy how like they can
say whatever they want politically oh
yeah and there's nothing and then you do
the exact same thing they did but for
your beliefs and they're like shut them
down fire him I do think it's oz in the
Dana's laughing and he's like no yeah
that's great because a lot of a lot of
Major League Sports they they have in
their contracts they'll go to the player
the athlete and be like you really gotta
tone it down you know like we're getting
we're getting heat I think people who
have Fu money need to start acting like
they got Fu money yeah what are they so
scared of it's the weirdest thing but
you know you know it might be it might
be that UFC is
I I think it's just a bunch of high
testosterone dudes aren't going to be
told what they can and can't do it's one
of the last bastions of masculinity
right exactly you know I mean not for
not for nothing it's it's and and it
people will say there's toxicity and
stuff but it's totally not because those
the guys like you are so well trained so
disciplined and so focused it is not
like just you know like you were talking
earlier like just raw emotion you have
to be smart we were talking earlier
about getting under your opponent's skin
and talking talking trash and how how
that's an important part and I think
that that's a good thing for young men
to do I like I think young men should
get into Jujitsu you know especially
like young people I think should be fine
like and then if you get older and you
want to get into striking sports that
you know more power to you but like that
kind of stuff is really good for young
men because it's a great way to get
expel energy you learn about yourself
you learn about respecting other people
and you know learning your limits and
stuff so I think that I think that the
UFC plays in important role today for
young men
um to to be able to express their their
masculinity in a positive way
I love the uh I crushed his dreams you
know
hilarious
dreams let me get you guys kicked off
YouTube saying to me words you know I
get locked in the cage it's okay if I
leave someone to pull blood but oh dang
he says some mean words cancel that guy
that's the funny thing though I like we
talk about all the time how in movies
there's murder there's death there's
chaos but then someone 10 years ago did
a bad joke so they gotta get fired from
their job yeah they say nothing about in
fact they cheer you on that you're you
and another guy are attempting to
mercilessly beat each other to prove
that you're the better fighter and
they're like that's cool and then you're
like I like Donald Trump they're like
shut it down they're like that's
violence
oh my God not the actual show itself
they're like well you know we understand
fighting is a sport but no you know like
it's like it's almost like
the leftist version of UFC is two guys
going to a ring and start talking about
how much who likes Trump more than the
other guy
you like Trump the most it's two guys
saying things about why Trump is good
why they like Western civilizations
gendering each other yep and they're
like it's just the most violence they've
ever seen who can take it for the
longest oh my gosh take it from the one
you said Trump beat up my dad I'm
tapping
it's too much it's too much and then
it's like there's low blows dude just
literally the
the micro uh microaggression Division
I was watching I was watching that fight
a couple weeks ago where um I can't
remember who it was uh who was it was it
um but one guy accidentally hit the
other guy in the nuts and then they
immediately backs off and he puts his
like sorry about that and they're like
no it's cool it's cool we can go again
like that's like a big No-No right like
you know yeah we like you know that's
not that's not Sportsman like yeah it's
not a sportsman like but you know
sometimes In the Heat of battle you know
it's tough to control your weapons you
know sometimes you're throwing a body
kick and it goes a little low it might
hit the nuts but that's why we wear a
cup in there so you can't feel that you
get kicked in the nuts you're not gonna
feel that with the cup on so all right
on yeah so I just but I imagine if the
leftists are getting in the ring it's
like you have a moment where someone
says something and they're like whoa
whoa whoa whoa like that that's an
illegal move you can't say that that's
too violent you know saying something
like Trump 2024 and they're like whoa
whoa
the the real extreme stuff is that's not
a penis yeah that's a wound that's
what's up that's not a vagina that's
what sucks about the media MMA media
they're all liberal like they all hate
Trump they all just they all just bash
them constantly and they don't want to
give me a platform they never want to
speak to me so you know it's just funny
because none of them none of them are
actual journalists none of them have
journalism degrees but they want to act
like they're journalists I mean I I I'll
I hate the journalism degree thing I
suppose there was yeah shame is a
journalist I think back in the day it
probably made some sense we were I was
talking about this today with my family
that we're you know we're in we're in
West Virginia in the small town the
newspaper used to just be like a
bulletin board seriously like the news
was like a guy fell off his ladder and
hurt his leg you live in the city and
you pick up the newspaper it's like John
fell yesterday and you're like oh John
fell wow and there's only a few thousand
people so most people knew sort of who
everybody was now nobody cares at all
about who their neighbor is and you can
have a house burned down across the
street from you and be like what
happened that was a fire I don't even
know who lived there now like we
completely separated ourselves from from
all information on the stuff well with
the political bias it's extra bizarre
and and you know you're talking about
the UFC here and the fact that UFC
journalists are on the left I understand
that journalists are usually uh lefties
but UFC is not like some flowery
left-wing thing that's why it's so
bizarre right yeah they want us all to
be betas but we're all Alphas you know
they don't want you know masculine men
in society you know they that's not
their agenda that doesn't fit their
agenda I just don't like are they doing
their little like critical theory
analysis on the fights or how does that
even work I I I I think the the reason
they're
I think UFC allows like you know like I
was saying Dana White because it's like
high testosterone guys who are just like
after you've been punched in the face so
many times words kind of roll off your
back like they didn't even happen it
doesn't matter but these journalists are
genuinely terrified words they hurt them
yeah these Millennials these genziers
who have never experienced anything and
it's funny because people are we've had
a couple super chats we're like these
these guys have never even been punched
in the face like talking about us and
like we're gonna sit here and talk with
you and it's like no I've definitely
been punched in the face bro yeah I've
been uh I've and and uh I've been in in
in uh I'll keep it light like conflict
crisis and and I don't want to say overt
War but I've been in places where people
are shooting at each other and I've
watched people die not that I've been
directly punched in the face I've had
anti I've had antifa try to punch me in
the face but I mean look like listen
I'll put it this way oh oh I'm a white
Bell in Jiu Jitsu so I know what it's
like to get wrapped up okay so I know
but I'm here to say like fair point like
I don't I'm I I have I have no problem
being like I have no idea what it's like
to go up against the greatest fighters
in the world and win or lose and these
these these leftists act like they do
know I know and I totally get that and I
I agree but I just don't know how anyone
could hear me speak and come to the
conclusion that no one's ever punched me
in the face
are you kidding me oh my gosh oh I think
the best thing about MMA media is just
they all write with their their bias and
their feelings they don't write
impartial journalism they don't say they
don't call a spade a spade you know they
dance around it and it's just sad what
do you think you think most Fighters are
probably right leaning
I would say it's a mix I'd say it's half
and half but I'm like how do you how do
you be a fighter and a leftist I just
don't understand that yeah true I mean
some of the guys are vegetarians or
vegans and all about the soy boy life
and safe spaces and this and that wow
and I think it's also like the
particular brand of left-wing politics
right because I don't think a lot of I
mean maybe I'm wrong but I don't think a
lot of them are gonna be like feminists
but I could definitely see like the BLM
thing but I can see appealing to men in
the MMA but these these these vegan
Fighters they're not like heavyweights
right no they're like middleweights
lighter weights because I don't I I I'm
not trying to rag on anybody's vegan I
got no problem with that you know live
your life do what you want to do just
please be healthy and if you are awesome
yeah but it's really hard to maintain
higher weights like I was I was reading
interviews with uh Hemsworth Chris
Hemsworth talking about playing the role
of Thor and he was he was saying he was
eating thousands of calories of Fish and
Chicken every day to try and maintain
that muscle mass and it's really really
hard constant training eating like crazy
and then once you stop you start going
back down
so I'm like I don't know I I kind of
feel like maybe it's just my bias but if
you're if if if if you can take a hit if
you can fight at the highest level how
are you gonna be the kind of person
that's like words are violence you know
what I mean you're gonna be like I don't
care what you call me dude I just got
punched in the face it hurts well that's
the other like I I think a lot of it is
just based on this is my side of the
aisle again you mentioned like the BLM
thing uh I could totally see that and I
think a lot of it just becomes like
tribal politics you know my family was
Democratic growing up or my family's
Republican growing up and that's why I'm
into this and not you know my gender
studies Professor told me words are
violence or something like that I would
suspect most of the people in the UFC on
the left aren't coming at it from the
blue haired college student angle
yeah no most Fighters you know didn't go
to college and yeah they're rather dumb
so I mean they get most of their
information from either social media or
mainstream media and when we know how
how controlled that is you know and how
much fake news is out there so you know
these these kids and fighting are a lot
of sheep you know they don't they can't
think for themselves or do do the
research to find out the real
information they just read a news
article like that on New York Times and
they just believe what it says
automatically thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there